started the game has started and it was
actually a line that i wanted to see in
the first game and uh they're playing it
what's happening david yeah so it's uh
it started as the reti opening and now
it's gone into a variation we call the
king's indian attack not the king's
indian defense which is normally for
black where you kind of react to one d4
here white has set up in this exact same
way the king's indian formation if you
look at the white king the white bishop
in front of it this is the king's indian
but it's the king's indian attack simply
because you have white you have the
extra move you get the center and
there's actually a pawn sacrifice on
show right now from magnus carlsen but
i'm not sure whether ding is going to
accept the sacrifice clearly the
computer look at the bar it thinks black
can get greedy and grab a pawn ding
meanwhile smiling slightly head in his
hands because he's trying to work out
what is happening and um right now black
has a nice pawn structure but if you
want to be ambitious if you want to be
greedy you might grab this pawn in the
middle of the board this pawn is
actually
under fire twice after a recapture of
the black knight can pounce but magnus's
whole idea is that he's not
materialistic he doesn't care about
pawns he's just going to jump into the
center with his knight and look at this
white bishop suddenly it has a whole
bunch of targets and this sacrifice is
actually long term as well even if we
see a trade of knights even if we see a
trade of queens then in this type of
position magnus has a huge advantage
because black's bishop is locked in at
home forever look at the two white
bishops pointing towards this side of
the board black's pieces on that side
under pressure never going to get out
and i think despite the pawn deficit
white has a winning advantage i don't
think ding should get greedy
it's tempting but here you have plenty
of choice for black you can just maybe
push a pawn forward that's very typical
um what else could you play
i mean you could move your bishop maybe
lots and lots of choice like
simon do you think he's going to capture
this pawn um
i don't think ding likes defending too
much
so if he takes that he's going to he's
going to go into defending game for the
rest of the game
okay he's material up but i think he
prefers sacrificing material and this
this setup from magnus is actually to my
eyes very very unique uh black's gone
for the french defense uh set up i do
very often against the king's indian
attack
and i've never seen this kind of a4 move
and the other advantage of magnus's pawn
over here is it stops black's normal
plan which is advancing his b pawn so
you're trying to get some space on the
queen side as well and so i'm just
wondering what what black should do here
uh it's not so easy to find a straight
straightforward plan and magnus has a
number of ways he can proceed so an
interesting position to my eyes at least
if it is there so it is the french
defense
it's yeah it's a french defense set up
that that black's played yeah well and
then i can tell you that before today
that had been played only six times so
far when i say it is maybe i'm not
really sure it kind of is i might be
cheating there a little bit black's kind
of gone for a french defense but not
against e4 i don't know it's like half
already opening half of french defense
yeah it's a hybrid a love love child of
the french defense well if it is a
french then that has a very good score
for for uh black this season uh 58
yeah that's huge yeah especially for an
opening which kind of has been frowned
upon at the very very top level for
years the french defense i mean it's a
perfectly viable opening it leads to
really fun positions for both sides but
you very rarely see the world champion
the top few in the world play it so and
retty 50 50. 50 50. yeah yeah only um 10
games played
uh sorry yeah 10 games played and it's
50 50. four wins for black four wins for
white we've seen two reties now between
these two so the first one was a draw
let's grab the porn david as well 50
opening then yeah he doesn't pawn up
though and uh i actually showed this on
the analysis board a few months ago it
looks pretty good for white if black
kind of
just goes for simple trades and swaps
everything off and he has done that yeah
look at the clock times as well magnus
he's played every move instantly i mean
this must be home preparation from
magnus you'd imagine because uh
you sack a pawn you must have looked it
at home even if you can see this
compensation it's not something
you really should go into blind
blindfolded um so he must know that
white's just got at least adequate well
you thought it was really good
conversation dave you really like
white's position right at least if i'm
seeing this for the first time
fresh i haven't studied it for black i
would be terrified to take a pawn and
look at those white bishops now they're
just beautiful maybe there are ideas
such as counter-attacking against the
white bishop in the center now
maybe black could offer a trade of
dart-squared bishops
yeah
i think you shouldn't rush to trade the
queens the tension you should wait for
your opponent to take the queens you
don't want to lose a move spend the move
uh exchanging on your opponent's terms
so i think queen takes queen here would
be a mistake from ding yeah it certainly
improves the placing of white's rook but
i agree with you i mean black probably
should be looking at uh locking out the
dark squared bishop as you mentioned
because white's
light squared bishop
that's a beast
it's never going to be challenged
and
it's so difficult for ding to even come
up with a way to even think about
developing all his pieces on the left
side of the board
challenging times
and
whilst we're waiting for ding to make a
decision
well we do have a quiz of the day where
we're asking what is your best tip to
improve chess openings and everyone has
been so helpful i'm so generous i mean
it's so lovely to see and uh warren de
silva says that their top tip for
improving chess openings is to find and
this is really good advice a top player
who has mastered and regularly plays the
respective chess opening you're
interested in and analyze their games
so don't choose like what i called
jokingly a hobby player you know hobby
players like actually i'm going to
rephrase that because i came out wrong
so don't play so you know like a top
ground master who like occasionally
plays one opening choose one who
consistently plays it got it so okay
well we have seen
ding make some trades
i didn't expect that at all i don't
really understand could he not have done
the same thing with the queens on the
board
i mean here it just feels like white's
rook now on the open line it feels like
such great compensation black has
ignored the threat against his own
knight he's counter-attacking against
white's bishop in the center of the
board but
i mean i would be tempted to either
allow that trade or to push a pawn to
support white's bishop now um
maybe you can move that white bishop
away
lots and lots of options for magnus
carson but it is all to do with white's
active pieces white's rook on the open
line white's bishop's pointing towards
um the left side where there will be
serious pressure later
simon what do you think
yeah i kind of liked your your pawn move
kind of uh
look nice i mean the problem is if you
if you take the bishop here and maybe we
can show it out which bishop takes
bishop a natural move can't be bad the
knight recaptures and it seems like the
black knight is quite well positioned
here to help the black bishop develop i
mean it's all about black developing his
his pieces here um so i don't really
want that knight to get to that square
so that's why if we go back a couple of
moves to the current position uh the
move
pawn the to f4 uh seems quite
interesting because again if you have
the exchange of bishops like before
the difference now is that black's
bishop can't move and the black knight
is also in some trouble here um where
does it go it might be lost it might
just be losing this position well okay
you can maybe defend it somehow but i
kind of like the pawn move i mean that
that feels like a logical move to me but
maybe maybe there's you know there's a
lot of ways you can play this position
even
even playing bishop takes knight is
maybe not ridiculous
but i wouldn't really want to do that
move that's kind of the last we've given
you the bishop pair uh unless i unless i
had to really so so this bishop
i mean you're right there simon just by
process of elimination as well um if we
backtrack to the current position
white's pawn pushing forward um what can
black actually play here his knight is
completely utterly trapped and the black
knight is under fire you have to trade
off these bishops i think you have to
support it with the black pawn and uh
at the very very minimum there will be
lines such as capturing this night and
jumping in with the white knight i mean
maybe nicely free there david it gives
you a horrible knight d2 but knight c3
uh before capturing on e4 because again
it's all about black's queen side how
does black get his queen side out and
you can get this kind of position where
it's so hard for black to develop
and the a pawns very well it looks very
comfortable for white and i would say
that again
magnus's preparation has been
a notch above ding
but last time this happened ding did
take control later on when magnus made a
mistake
i mean saying that though
magnus has a very easy position to play
here so it's very hard to
to to go wrong i guess i actually love
this position for white and i love the
move that dave is highlighting but also
the white rook on the corner could also
mobilize up a3 and start attacking some
pawns
and oh
bishop is just stuck at home black has
no control over the dark squares black
is temporarily one point up but
i mean i think it's more than sufficient
compensation for white here
and as simon mentioned
this is pretty much instantly possible
in the current position that position is
almost forced if white pushes his pawn
forward now and protects his bishop
i mean just looking at all the options
this looks by far the most tempting you
also have
very many alternatives after a trade
and in this position for example the
other one i mentioned just trading off
yes you kind of have this night for
bishop imbalance but if you compare the
pieces
white knight is about to regain the uh
extra pawn for black and it's going to
sit on a beautiful outpost uh that black
can never challenge in just a couple of
moves
um yeah it looks like a magnus type of
position it's not just the fact he might
have an advantage objectively it's a
magnus type of position it's not a type
of position that ding likes to defend
and uh that makes me think that okay
ding now head in his hand
makes me think the opening has been a
success for white yeah and you both
mentioned how magnus has been very well
prepared in this particular line and i
just want to talk to you about a
question from stardog who says
mag do you think that magnus is still
training as befits a full professional
or does he no longer
spend the whole chest take the whole
chest thing so seriously
it says maybe david knows
um i mean i don't think we can question
magnus's professionalism right yeah i
think he's still number one by a big
distance he's still a world champion he
still wins most tournaments he plays in
but do you think he's kind of like do
you think he's training
like
eight hours a day he talked about this
in the puma interview right with kashin
vardhan that
his aim now is to reach 2900 right and
he said that if i want to do that i have
to
give it 100 every single day everything
i do i you know everything i eat
everything i sleep
has to evolve around that because it's
going to be so difficult so maybe it's
about having that goal for him yeah i
mean he definitely has some goals left i
mean he's talked about the world
championship that's one thing that's i
think let's keep that separate for now
but he still wants to win every game you
can see that day-to-day on the tour um
we talked about 2900
i mean he works out all the time with
the view to chess he still has full-time
coaches employed like peter heiner
nielsen you don't do that if you're not
professional
so i don't think that could be
questioned i think he's still
got plenty to give and
um okay interesting moment uh i just got
distracted by the game because white's
given up another pawn and here white is
two pawns down
but he's got maximum control over the
position um if you look on this long
diagonal the white long diagonal towards
that black rook everything is just
trapped for black black can never move
his light squared bishop out
interesting decision and a very
professional decision magnus carlsen i
feel
and yeah i mean i would already be
terrified for survival for ding despite
the computer saying 0.0 it's just about
whether magnus can improve the white
rooks
two pawns is a lot but yes
in control so i i do love games like
this
because
okay it's two pawns but it's like you're
always thinking about what your opponent
can do and uh just look at black's queen
side pieces he's two pieces down he's a
rook down in the corner and a bishop
down in the corner and these these guys
they need to get out at some point
otherwise you just lose and uh it's
quite artistic that they just can't
really get out i mean you can't move the
bishop because it gets captured by the
brook
and if you can't move the bishop you
can't move the rook um you can't
fianchetto the bishop so if you try
moving the b pawn well you'll lose your
rook it'll be captured by white's pawn
for example
so how on earth do you ever get those
queen side pieces out and it's really uh
i find these positions extremely
picturesque um you know just real
torture like you know tying your
opponent down um i mean you still have
to win it you still have to progress
somehow uh which is the next stage but
it's it's it's very tricky for ding i
think this this particular position yeah
for example simon if the black bishop
goes back now i think magnus will
instantly push this pawn forward just to
stop black from uh kind of pushing in
the center and freeing up his bishop
here and i mean for example if you give
black a time out maybe he can push his
pawn get his bishop out somehow maybe he
can survive if he freezes pieces but
magnus will not allow that maximus will
just push his pawn forward and he'll say
okay now you can't break here if you
can't break here it means your bishop
brooker trapped as you mentioned there
simon and
i don't see what black's gonna do over
the next 10 15 moves
still you need to win it as white i'm
not sure exactly what the winning plan
is maybe you could combine pushing on
this side of the board
with maybe putting some pressure on
black's queen side here you can kind of
combine two ideas but
how depressing is it going to be for
ding if he has to just sit and wait and
do nothing yeah also this black rook can
never challenge the central line as well
this open file is completely dominated
by white because this key square is
controlled by the white bishop black's
rook can never fight
for that key line
i do feel that white can probably take
his pick of the plans you know maybe
advance as much as possible on the right
side of the board in a very safe way
that keeps control and then when he
chooses to he can initiate operations on
the left when it's great for him what
about this plan at some point whoops
sorry bringing the white king over and
just winning and entering the
position if you have that luxury maybe
you have the time i torture that's great
yeah okay he doesn't push this pawn i'm
surprised instead he goes after this
black pawn
uh maybe it's still good maybe this
black pawn push in the center trying to
free up the black bishop is not actually
so effective but i'm surprised i thought
why not lock it down
as much as possible
if you could
so i'm expecting ding at some point to
try and push this pawn just to free up
his trapped pieces over here
and yeah meanwhile i'm very surprised
the evaluation bar says 0.0 because
we're miles miles away from any draw
here ding has to fight just to survive
wow just to get his pieces out okay
sticking for him he has uh four minutes
less than magnus on the clock in what
david describes as almost a desperate
situation
getting close to it maybe yeah it's just
a full bind um
it's as if someone's just kind of
trapped you in a prison cell and you
just can't escape um
thrown away the key
how'd you get out python's strategy at
its finest right just totally squeezing
the life out of the position
um hurts
i think this is my favorite type of
chest like simon referenced as well
because
every move comes with a point and it
comes with intelligence and just take a
look at blacks you know pieces
those on the left can't move and those
on the right they're just
don't know what to do
and uh it's like you've kind of
bamboozled your opponent
literally what can ding even do here i
mean he has to push a pawn near the
black king well now he finally pushes
his central pawn
yeah i think he needed to do this i
still like your move better david you're
f4 than what magnus has done um probably
don't tell him that i don't know but um
because at least black's getting his
pieces out now we were talking about
black's queen side and um i mean again
magnus moves the rook but
you have some chances to get your queen
side pieces out now because you've been
allowed to at least free your position
up a little bit by that last pawn move
but what's what's magnus plan now is
rookie free just wants to win some pawns
back i guess yeah um you mentioned that
black's bishop can come out at some
point and for example it can come out
now and attack the white rook gain a bit
of time but even if the white rook just
moves i'm not exactly sure where for
example but if it just slides across one
square now there's a double attack
against this pawn two white rooks lining
up
but also this black pawn
is about to drop for example if you
guard your central pawn it's not just
the fact that this pawn drops to the
white bishops but once the black rook
moves away now from the attack it's the
corner pawn that drops and suddenly
white has a past pawn on this side of
the board and we might see something
similar in the game later uh meanwhile
in the current position black has indeed
guarded in the center and i'm expecting
magnus now to try and make use of this
pin
to try and push his pawn forward and
we're only in move 21 would you say this
is a success out of the opening for
magnus massive success wow yeah i mean
it's just very one-sided traffic again i
think in order to save this game ding
needs to give back his extra pawns and
then get his pieces active
but that's still yeah that's still a
long long way away it's a distant dream
at the moment ding
just getting his pieces out let alone
equalizing let alone holding the draw
and it's actually
magnus carlsen's uh main man his second
his trainer peter heine nielsen's
birthday today
so i guess a good way for mine is to
celebrate him by playing something great
in the opening that probably peter has
been involved in somehow i think it's
eric hanson's 30th birthday as well is
it a happy birthday to eric hansen and a
happy birthday to peter heiner nelson
birthday
and uh yeah peter heiner i
definitely feel the kind of pete heiner
nielsen's touch on this opening it feels
like he's fed magnus with this type of
idea and magnus has taken it to another
level put it on the board
and yeah i mean no great chess player
can come up with great opening ideas
every single day you need that team
around you so
and that do you know how old peter hine
is turning today yes do you know it yes
because you're not allowed to answer
okay oh my god i hate getting asian if
you're gonna guess
oh no
i'm four four fifty forty five forty six
seven forty it's actually forty nine
forty nine cause i was just super
shocked
and i saw he looks like and i mean i you
know not even as a compliment i really
mean it i thought maybe maybe 40 maybe
40. oh wow yeah he's getting close to
50. my maths was wrong there i remember
playing him in a youth versus experience
event in
2010. i know he's been around a bit so
that's why he was a bit older yeah yeah
so i mean
he was in the experience section at 2010
he was only in his 30s what's up with
that
cheating
great player though as well as a second
coach yeah and helping magnus to some
great success probably
in the opening of this game still liking
it for magnus yes um i like the fact
that ding's bishop is out that ding's at
least not completely trapped within his
prison within his cage any longer but
still some serious questions once so we
mentioned white's light squared bishop
going and taking one of black's pawns
you still have to defend against that
black's pawn in the centre of the board
is about to fall
and uh i don't think you can keep
everything intact
i'm trying to find a move here for black
to be honest i'm still struggling and
ding five minutes down on the clock it's
an end game but
it's not a typical type of end game
where you can just calculate your way
out where you can rely on previous
knowledge pattern recognition this is
very unique
this type of situation if i had to
choose i probably would try to hold on
to the the b7 pawn was what i was going
to say you know give up the center one i
hope that that one gets taken off
because at least then the bishops get
some freedom um
but magnus is not gonna do
he's not gonna just get greedy and
capture pawns i think he's gonna try to
keep control
yeah i mean how do you keep control that
is the question for magnus carlsen now
uh because there is the option of
capturing black central pawn with your
own pawn restoring some semblance of
material parity but
what next
that's the big question and if you don't
go for that as you mentioned ivanka
what are the options
do you just push pawns forward for
example white's h pawn can steps forward
one square attacking black slight
squared bishop that was my vibe that's a
start yeah take some space
ask questions where that light square
bishop is going to go
yeah this light square bishop doesn't
have too many squares so you could kick
it away
hit it first of all
and yeah i'm not sure where it's going
to be honest okay magnus takes the uh
kind of more direct approach the route
one approach he
captures his opponent in the center and
if ding recaptures then suddenly a bit
of a question for this bishop
this bishop doesn't have too many
squares it's only real safe squares this
one and then white can actually gain
back uh both of the lost pawns so now
it's level material it's not just level
material but white still has this target
long term okay ding didn't want to go
for this he didn't want to open things
up but he's now with this pawn push a
loud white a very nice past pawn
there is a threat in the position uh
black bishop wants to come and skewer
the two white rooks they're both on the
same diagonal but this white pawn is
surely going to be i think that's a
plastic strength a mistake it feels like
there's a you know feels like there's
something wrong
here because you're like the white rook
has now the possibility of going to the
seventh rank i i realized there is a
trick
but as you mentioned but
could
i mean i'm not sure if it's anything
direct i don't think you need to be
directive for magnus carlsen i think
it's just a bit too desperate for ding
and for example um if let's just do
nothing let's give a check i want to
force the black king in the corner and
then i just want to get out of this uh
this kind of skewer so
one of the rooks i mean the white rock
can go this way or it can go back but
say i just play an unambitious move
let's go back i again don't see really
what black is doing long term you have
to keep an eye on this pawn which means
your rook is tied down forever and at
some point this white pawn is going to
push forward tie down this black bishop
i don't think you need to be direct
black's pieces are still not great the
king the
rook um one-way traffic i feel
i mean maybe there's something
uh direct there ivanka as you mentioned
maybe i thought maybe kick back the
bishop okay
not possible do possibly allow yeah
counter-attack against these rooks
so
i mean i i just feel like magnus has
done the hard work he's yes he's still
one point down but it's not a porn
that's important and why not just
retreat just keep everything nice and
safe
at the right moment bring your bishop in
or bring your rook in
and walk push this pawn what is black
doing in the meantime i don't really see
it
yeah okay ding meanwhile leaving the
board briefly with his back and magnus
still thinking in the current position
lots of choice for him i think um sorry
this pawn might be the winner long term
what's the name of the e pawn simon you
know all the names
well i was calling him eddie um after
eddie the eagle who's quite a famous
character in uh norway as well right i
mean it's where he
trained but he was
the ski jumper who was who was pretty
terrible but everyone loved him because
he's the only ski jumper from england
it's a movie about him it's a great
movie actually eddie the eagle yeah
really really worth watching um but yeah
i i just agree with everything you're
saying i mean it looks
really hard for black um
it's a horrible position to have to play
for black as well i mean you're under
pressure you haven't really had any
chance to break out
this last move i also don't like i think
he should have exchanged some pawns off
and just try to pray uh of surviving in
some ending but by keeping more pawns on
the board you're also allowing white
just have this very strong past pawn in
the middle of the board this this pawn
that can come you know maybe just win
the game at some point so so yeah eddie
yeah that's it so uh so in general i i
think if magnus is careful here it could
be really tough and um that also i mean
the way things are going uh the final i
you know i wanted to see i'll be honest
um nothing against the other players but
um these two have had some great matches
and they've always gone in prague's way
it would be magnus carlsen versus prague
and prague has beaten magnus on a couple
of occasions now and i just think that
would be a great final like you know
maybe a future world champion against
the current world champion so that that
for me i mean again enough nothing
against the niche is played brilliantly
nothing against ding is a fantastic
player but for me that's kind of the
final you know i would like to see just
because i think it'd be fascinating um
if i could pick a final before the whole
tournament that would be it so it's like
yeah so it's it's uh it's looking like
that as possible there's a lot to happen
still yet of course but i've said there
would be excitement in in many of those
matchups imagine also like ding against
the niche ding is ready for the
candidates and he just about missed it
and he would then be eager to show that
i should have been in the candidates
and ding mentioned in his interview
yesterday he's made it to the
semi-finals several times actually on
the tour but he's never got to a final
yet so it'll be depressing for ding if
he gets beaten again he always seems to
meet with magnus carlsen
it's just like this big boss blockading
your path to the winning the tournament
always on the wrong side of the bracket
yeah um i mean ding
we're writing him off i mean this game
is looking very very difficult for him
now just because black can barely move
but uh he will have white in the last
game even if he falls to defeat here he
can strike back so yeah all four finals
i mean anyone could get to the final
here and then of course prague again if
he uh goes to the final he has to start
off tomorrow with exams yeah
and then start playing against whether
he'll get like special dispensation or
something you know i was wondering why
enough is he bothering and i mean he's
clearly going to be like a chess
professional yeah you know just just
pull out a school you don't need to go
what was even bothering you
listen to assignments
i'm just saying unless you unless you
can be world champion and then it's okay
to pull out of school but i mean if
you're if you're that strong and your
future is going to be chess you know who
doesn't need to learn about some
engineering stuff okay bad advice but i
can i can see why he's doing it you have
to you have to finish the school with
certain qualifications right it's not a
must yeah you probably have to and it is
obviously good to get an education yeah
i hear um you say like yeah
but i mean uh you know he's playing the
world champion maybe so that that what's
more important exactly well i do see the
bar maybe slightly over to anish geary's
side in game three and she has to make a
comeback because prague is in the lead
in that match and then this one the bar
is
you know creeping up for magnus more and
more david has been saying it for a long
time it looks really good for the world
champion in this game yeah and he's
really playing with all the angles all
the geometrical kind of motifs here
magnus he's just lifted his rook up one
square this rook's got a real journey
but uh the rook now on the fourth rank
pins black's pawn blacks pawn on the
file to the black bishop so just trying
to completely immobilize black and ding
he's trying to be active i think he's
doing the right thing he's pushing pawns
he's trying to create a distraction if
white's pieces get distracted or if
white's pieces get traded off especially
the bishops then ding might be okay
temporarily he's still a pawn up
so okay can magnus
up the pressure
and if so how
um maybe the white e pawn can step
forward maybe white's dark square bishop
there's so much choice i think the one
trap that magnus shouldn't fall into in
this position because he is upon down is
taking this guy viewers at home might
wonder why not take a pawn back why not
uh restore the material balance the
reason is because after a trade here
for example black can start getting
pieces off the board black can start
trading rooks trading pieces and maybe
there will be a path to survival maybe
black just moves across and starts
targeting your pawns i think you
shouldn't free up
your opponent with exchanges even if you
win a pawn in the process so in this
position magnus has brought his bishop
forward kicking away this black rook
and i think the reason is if the black
rook for example challenges the bishop
he might well offer the exchange but
he'll offer it and a way that gives him
a past pawn
i'm still not convinced by this to be
honest but uh white does have a very
dangerous passport now
eddie has become david and the d pawn
and uh meanwhile this pawn is still
under fire i mean well
it's certainly good for magnus but it's
not winning by any means here i mean
that i think what you're showing on the
board here is very likely to occur um
but there's going to be more exchanges
and black can start attacking that d
pawn now but maybe by i don't know rook
d8 or rook six one of these moves but um
yeah and okay i mean yeah you might win
the a pawn but pawns are getting swapped
off um pretty pretty quickly here and
the more pawns that get swapped off
they're nearer to a potential draw and i
think uh dingler would be very happy
just to swap some pieces off and get out
the bind he's been under this bind for
so long that this this looks like a
quite a big improvement to me actually
for black on what's happened previously
so
and i was just going to add you know the
optimus
optimist in black should actually be
looking at the fact that
ding also has a past pawn freddy the f
pawn which you know if magnus misplays
things could be something to uh be happy
about yeah it's not that far away from
promotion
at some point so yep this one is
definitely something to keep an eye on
in the current position ding's rook is
under attack however and he should move
it
a couple of squares he can choose from
he can slide across one square as we
just showed or he can maybe
uh slide across the hallway but that
looks a bit odd uh just stuck behind his
own bishop
much more natural to play the attacking
move yeah
only two minutes left on the clock for
ding now yeah that's one worrying thing
i mean if he can't just kind of
completely clarify the tension if he
can't trade bishops trade works trade
get rid of pawns uh like simon was
indicating then the clock will become a
factor but if he can get rid of pieces
then i think he'll be much happier
okay i'm not sure why he spent so long
in that move it seemed pretty obvious
and okay he's gone for a much more
passive approach and um this is where
things can go wrong you know he's been
passive the whole game i don't know why
he doesn't want to get out of that
passive you know that passive kind of
way of going and it and you know this
this move might be all right but
now magnus maybe cash in on on his his
good play so far can't he just by
capturing starting to capture some bits
yeah catch b7 capture a6 this kind of
stuff
and he's going to have a lot of past
pawns in the position with the white
pieces start with this pawn if the rack
rook moves you can maybe consider this
pawn i guess sting's idea is that he
wants to get active with one black rook
and actually the white king might be a
bit of a factor
the white king lacking some say squares
for example if you step forward the
black bishop can start coming to check
you on this diagonal magnus therefore
before going pawn hunting before getting
greedy and grabbing this pawn which
isn't really running away
he captures here and after black takes
back
maybe the same idea maybe you just take
this pawn maybe you just bring your king
forward and uh start going after freddie
the fborn that ivanka mentioned as a
potential uh kind of threat
for black this pawn is quite strong
okay key key moment
does magnus get greedy cash in
i think it's very human i would be too
tempted i think i see a pawn i take a
pawn but magnus has hesitated
yeah there's a couple of tempting moves
there aren't there but maybe
and he's gone for another option he's
trying to activate his rook on the
seventh rank this is the kind of
position he plays very well normally but
okay you can see the evaluation bar has
has changed i don't know if that's gonna
give black some hope so you don't think
it's a bad move i don't think it's
really a bad move i don't think it's a
blunder but it's uh maybe there was some
better moves here
in the position previously and but it's
the kind of move that puts pressure
right on yeah yeah yeah especially with
the time situation
yeah it's very practical move as well
and his internet's gone again look at it
quad here
but he does look so happy i've never
seen him smile so much in the picture he
should win this game with that smile
can't you get a miserable picture of him
for the last one
you know sir he's uh according to the
position that he's in you know how like
you know smile yeah
oh you can change it depending yeah yeah
that'd be clever well but we prefer the
webcams because then we get the live
image of that right the big smiles and
the frustration yeah and it is
frustration for doing look at him you
can see it on his body language how
frustrated and nervous he is i mean one
minute on the clock yeah and still a lot
of problems to solve for black we
mentioned some of the pawns under fire
but it's the white rook coming in and
ivanka mentioned this is an annoying
move to face here we see the stockfish
evaluation stockfish moves
only one move keeps the balance for
black
it's not that obvious i would say it's
definitely possible to find this the
best move for black is to actually move
the black brick on the air file down the
board two squares hitting white pawn in
the middle the david the deep one um the
far advanced pawn but
that does require some calculation do we
think he's going to find it is that
natural
well he's only got 40 seconds now i mean
i would imagine if you know if he hasn't
found it by now he won't find it i mean
it's so much more normal to try and swap
some pieces off i mean who wouldn't put
the rook on the open file here i think
most people would just go to swap off
and pray
is he going to find it this rook move
it's the best one by quite a distance as
simon mentioned it's maybe more natural
however to bring one of the black rooks
across to challenge white's rook that's
the second best move it's not losing but
it does give white a big advantage
so okay ten seconds ten seconds to find
this seconds is he going to find it
rooked f6 i think he might fight what
five seconds
oh he's played it wow that's amazing
with
so little time this is why he's well
number two right to find moves like that
is is incredible so little time
left on the clock so
now yeah very well done ding and maybe
one of the ideas is actually to go after
the white king so you've actually
cleared a path for your other rook to
swing across for example if the white
bishop takes your pawn the other black
rook is going gonna swing across and
start hitting the white king now and uh
for example if the white king moves
forward there are ideas such as the
rooks lining up and uh it's an end game
but you're going on the attack so it's
still very complicated but the best move
this is the difference as well with
these players i mean they they can cope
so well with the pressure i mean most
mortals there would just start crumbling
they look at their clock 10 seconds left
and they would do some desperate move
but these guys they find rook f6 that is
that you know that keeps the game alive
really impressive stuff from ding and uh
uh you know it's it's again it's not to
my eyes this is just not so clear i mean
white is better but it's not that
obvious we're also being i mean you've
called it david the d pawn
okay but uh key moment now this pawn is
actually under fire so magnus needs to
defend it and the only way that i see to
defend it is to move your bishop out of
the way uh for example by taking this
ball now you defend it with your rook
but um as soon as this bishop moves as
we mentioned this square is lost uh
magnus has lost control of so um this
would be a very annoying check so magnus
now he's spending his time just trying
to work out the consequences of this
track he decides he doesn't want to
allow it but now stepping his bishop
back he's keeping an eye on the square
so the black rook can't use it but he's
lost a lot of time and ding is lining up
now against the d-pawn uh blackstroke
indirectly is going to start attacking
it soon and uh
things turning around
do you think he's gonna i'm gonna say
he's gonna hold it now okay we've got to
have a little little it was that well
due to this move rooker 6 the star move
that he found with five seconds left if
he wins that if he wins the d pawn then
i i he should be okay right
yeah just thought of a rhyme from the
wizard of oz okay let's hear it
the pawn is gone
i like it ding dong the porn is gone
yeah yeah yeah yeah how it goes it is
yeah yeah i think that was a you used
for yeah yeah something else wasn't it
um
um but yeah no that is from the wizard
of oz i can remember your only time
watch was the if you watch it the dark
side of the moon it's in it's in tune
that's something i did at university i
don't know if anyone else has done that
nope okay move on quickly
no
um but yeah i think he's gonna hold it
now i think he's got great chances and
magnus now has slowed down uh as well so
uh which indicates he's not maybe as
happy i wish we could see magnus because
i have a feeling he's shaking his head
right now i have a feeling he's just
thinking oh i had full control 100
control of the position
look at the black bishop in the center
of the board look at the black rope
behind it those pieces were on their
starting squares just 10 moves ago stuck
immobilized unable to break out and now
those pieces they're in the game they're
about to improve even further and
remember black is still one porn up
magnus he was going after a few pawns he
had the option of grabbing another
couple of black pawns he didn't take
that option and uh
he's got nothing to show for at magnus
carlsen i don't really see what he does
now the white rook in the center of the
ball can go up to the seventh rank but
actually everything's defended in
black's camp
he's having a big thing about it and uh
what's he going for so he's bringing
this in and now
yeah and uh black's
got his pieces out out of the position
and that black the bishop coming to c6
is going to be tremendous as well in
some cases white's king is actually a
big target white's king is not safe
could he lose this one you know it's a
full 360. yeah it's it's possible at
least wow what a tense match these two
are really bringing their a-game yeah i
mean we've seen this we've seen this all
the time you know that
one side puts the other under pressure
and the other one rises to the occasion
and uh here it's phenomenal defense by
ding
um
i i agree with you simon i think he
might be
in trouble magnus it's quite hard to
adjust doesn't it when you when you know
you're doing fantastically well and
suddenly like hang on a minute uh i
should be doing well you have to like
you have to tell yourself not to try win
too much
and that's when you can end up losing
the game and look at this bishop now
striking across the board uh combined
with a black rook coming in you can also
maybe just try to take this pawn in the
center you know magnus is okay don't get
me wrong in this position but it's
changing and that that's when it gets
different psychologically even if
difficult psychological even if you're
the world champion so uh um
i don't know i mean it's he's got to be
careful right i mean if magnus loses
this pawn he has no winning chances at
all he's destined to just defend a
difficult position so i'm wondering what
happens if magnus pushes forward
trying to keep this pawn alive it's
defended now by both white's rooks but
the black rook is going to start
breaking through with a series of checks
and here for example rook takes rook
simply and black can remove this pawn
from the board maybe with his rook maybe
with his bishop and black is two pawns
up two pawns
maybe even here white's just about okay
because of white's activity but it okay
magnus didn't like that so he he
understands he has to keep that pawn on
the board but now it's going for a rook
trade i mean is there an immediate
perpetual if if what if black wants it
maybe oh so that could give a check
hitting the white king the white king
has to step back this way to defend its
rook and uh simon you think maybe a
check
the white king's stepping back and a
draw well i mean i i think here you okay
he's playing for the win he's bringing
his king in he's a pawn up why not play
for the win your bishop is fantastic
your
your material up you bring your king to
the center you've got to take advantage
of these
playing for the win magnus has to be so
careful now
i mean you're just a pawn down at the
moment for nothing i think you have to
really try and find a genius way to save
this game at this point um okay the
white bishop's stepping back the thing
is the black king can enter the center
of the ward actually helping to attack
this pawn but i think the pawn is just
going to step up and maybe you can't
round it up maybe that's the one problem
for ding here this pawn is kept alive by
its rook and its bishop it does tie down
black's army in the meantime and we're
gonna see this position
and uh magnus he has nothing else he
does have to push this pawn all the way
forward what next for ding that is the
big question
yeah i mean i guess magnus is trying to
get rid of the bishops to get to uh um
okay that's an interesting move but to
try and simplify i thought he was um but
maybe that doesn't work to try you know
to try and simplify into a rook and pawn
ending and get a draw that way but it's
it's
it's black who's pushing here definitely
you have to keep your bishop defending
this pawn most likely i mean you could
move away
or you could step back stepping back
would make a lot of sense just defending
this pawn i think this is the most
likely the safest but uh for example you
could contemplate taking this pawn off
the board why can't you just take it
yeah suddenly you lose control over this
pawn so black can now remove
okay we have seen a different move but
here we could see for example uh pieces
getting traded i think this would end in
a draw uh instead we have seen if we go
back to the game position the bishops
have left the board and now it's all
about this pawn black is going back to
take it with his rook but now white is
going on a hunt as well for some pawns
himself i mean i thought this was fine
for magnus i thought it was his idea to
swap the bishops off try to simplify
into this
board and i don't think he i think this
is now too many things are getting
changed off i think it's it's calming
down eventually here heading towards a
draw now so black's still one pawn up
but this pawn is attacked and this pawn
is attacked we might end up in a rook in
game with same number of pawns and it's
just going to be a dead draw
and here we go ding yeah
he has secured the draw pretty much all
of the pawns are just getting wiped out
we're going to end up with just king and
rook versus king and rook nothing else
to do here yeah
wow very exciting game i mean
there was a lot of action there i mean
magnus brilliant opening idea but then
he kind of allowed ding to escape there
and um
you know there's not much between these
two are there at the moment and we did
see a reaction from ding i'm wondering
if that was like frustration i didn't
actually win it or just all right a draw
white pieces in the final rapid game
yeah i think that game was just
extremely stressful so he needs to get
out of there as quickly as possible
needs to refresh himself needs to reset
and yeah white in the last game i think
ding is maybe the favorite now after
defending a difficult position like that
he will feel unbeatable
what a semi-final match you guys between
world number one and world number two